searching at Sea almost two weeks on and
for police the choppy coastline is now
the focus as they continue to look for
missing Nicola bully
they're scouring Waters over 10 miles
Downstream from where the mum of two was
last spotted police believe day by day
finding her in the open sea becomes more
of a possibility
at the bench where Nicholas phone dog
Willow and its lead were found searching
has come to a halt investigators
confirmed resources are now being piled
into finding Clues further along this
Deep fast-flowing River if the police's
theory that Nicola bully accidentally
slipped into the river wire is true than
finding any trace of her Downstream will
prove incredibly difficult the tidal
nature of this River will cause almost
anything to move back and forth
constantly and the area to search
including the coast is vast
the size and scale and the expanse of
that area will obviously present
difficulties there are obviously
currents and and tidal uh flows to
consider uh that can take things in in
various Direction there will be sand
banks you've got hide side Lord side but
all these things will be factored in
with uh with other agencies partner
agencies who've got expertise in that
area who will be working with the police
uh to help them formulate the best
possible search parameters for that area
whilst of friends and family have
praised the efforts of the police for
them something doesn't add up they want
all possibilities of her disappearance
investigated
Friday morning marks two weeks since
Nicola left her home dropped off her
children at school and took her dog for
a walk it was nothing out of the
ordinary what was however is she didn't
come home a mystery for many an
agonizing fortnite for a family in Zaman
Rashid Sky News Lancashire